you are listening to the most original
talk radio station anyway we are la talk
radio at la talk radio com
film courage women
I'm away
but is this something new oh this is
brand-new this is brand-new and I also
have some breaking news for you oh so
basically the webisode competition um
you know obviously sponsored with
Hollywood unites for Haiti is going to
be judged by the creators of dr.
horrible's sing-along blog and that's
some you know that's some pretty big
that kind of set the president for all
for all um webisode series you know
that's the starring neil patrick harris
okay that's right hand Doogie Howser yes
Joss Whedon his brother Jed Whedon his
fiancee Marissa they're both the
creators of dr. horrible's sing-along
blog and they're also writers on
dollhouse they're gonna be judging the
webisode submissions so I think that
should be should be pretty cool um we
haven't announced that so alright yeah
yes yes I'm just met about then and um
so um so yeah they did you know we're
taking webisode submissions portion of
the proceeds go to Ali Hollywood unites
for Haiti and also we're gonna have a
big big big night at the festival
honoring the chosen webisodes that's
going to take place at the Chris in
Hollywood which is a massive nightclub
down there um so we're gonna have a huge
huge night at the at the rooftop at the
crest on saturday august eighth so um so
Jimmy will be there and some some other
celebrities